[Music]
i hereby
institute my american diary
i've just visited with mr everett the
state house of boston
where the adjutant general mr schuler
whom mr everett addressed as general
showed me a springfield rifle superior
to the enfield
the ogerton general was big good-natured
and grisly
went into the senate house 40 senators
present
i have today seen two statues of general
washington
and read two autographed letters of his
in 1756
george washington was writing sweetly to
mrs martha custis
whom he afterwards married he is very
polite but his jokes as
mr everett observed are somewhat
elephantine
sunday july 12th went to two sleepy
unitarian services
after the second service walked with mr
edward everett on to the common and so
home
mr everett discussed upon what had led
to lincoln's election
sketching the origin of the republican
party seward was the main organizer of
it
and would have been president but in the
chicago convention
local feeling ran so high that lincoln
was substituted for him
lincoln had the better of douglas in his
speeches and his national reputation
dated from his contest with douglas for
the senatorship
two years previously seward knew the
south well
and did not believe they would be easily
subjugated
mr everett greatly regretted the split
in the democratic party at the election
they should have united under some less
violent man than breckenridge
i visited the provost marshall's office
in this ward
400 out of 1 300 is about the proportion
drafted
there was a good deal of joking going on
in the crowded room
well for them that they can afford to
treat it so lightly
for the conscription act is a severe
measure two sons of mr everett and sons
of mr garrison
and mr winthrop have been caught as also
a young fellow whom i met last night
this considering how few names i know is
pretty well
no wonder there are riots in new york
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service so
quick update from coco she's been
inspired by the recent american election
and is now actually thinking about
running for office uh
who was your favorite candidate coco
[Music]
kanye west
luckily coco is better at choosing
documentaries than presidents
and her recommendation this week is a
deep dive into the making of the
american empire
and the incredible journey the country
has been on a great companion piece
to this video for those who don't know
magellan is a sort of netflix for
documentaries
it's got a huge range of great history
stuff and over 3 000 documentaries in
total
and growing so click on the link in the
description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voices of the past viewers
thanks
the canadians i've seen are almost all
southerners
i read yesterday lord palmerton's speech
on july 23rd in answer to cobden
about the shipbuilding he seems to me to
make too much of the difficulty there in
distinguishing between a ship intended
for commerce
and one meant for war what will he say
to the iron clads which i saw in mr
laird's yard before i left liverpool
i think the north will be fools if they
don't make a great effort
to have those stopped even if they have
to threaten war
i hope that we should not fight on such
a question i'm glad to see the
confederate loan in a bad way
no wonder people are frightened for
besides lee's army i don't see what else
formidable the south have left and i
think his army must be very much less
formidable than it was when jackson was
alive
[Music]
at syracuse mr samuel j may
a noted abolitionist treated me very
well and told me a great deal that was
interesting
he had been involved in the underground
railway
and says that they used to pass about
200 escaped slaves
every year through syracuse on the way
to canada
these people are all as keen about the
war as you can imagine
and the more educated and quiet looking
they are the keener they seem to be
in niagara i met an old gentleman from
kentucky the perfect picture
of old-fashioned america immensely tall
with a black felt hat
scrupulously dressed in black and
carrying a splendid
gold-headed cane he turned out to be
colonel
j wood who lives near the mammoth cave
in kentucky
he told me he was a slave owner but was
for the union for all that
as was an immense majority in kentucky
three battles were fought close to his
house and one of his sons was wounded
but the country is settled now it
astonishes me
how much curiosity there is everywhere
about the views of the english on the
war
some profess great disgust at the
support we have given the rebellion
but most expect that our opinion will
come over to their side in time
and this is what i expect mr lincoln is
by no means such a fool as we've been
taught to believe
he will leave behind him a great
reputation
philadelphia is only 100 miles from
gettysburg where the fighting was so
desperate just over two months ago
but the thronged streets and theaters
here don't look at
all like exhaustion and i'm quite
staggered by your letter and your
doubts about the pleasure of freedom in
the north for a slave
as compared with slavery in the south
if you really think slavery pleasanter
all i say is you don't know what slavery
is
and if you won't read and know what
slavery is you won't believe me who was
red and has got a certain idea about it
and also seen this terrible ill
treatment in the north
the result of which is that the black
population looks tidy and thriving
then you are i say intractable
and all i can do is assure you of my own
conviction and trust to events
to bring you round i am so certain
myself of the good
to humanity of this war that if the
north were not winning i should be
inclined to volunteer myself
and have a shot at some of those
accursed people whom you are all
praising so loudly
indeed i have a good mind to do it now
just to show that
all englishmen are not as selfish and
ignorant as most of them seem to be
i don't believe one could be killed in a
better course
however i am going to the west first and
i start on tuesday
i want to have a good idea of the
country before i see the armies
in the field
the struggle here is not so much between
two nations as between two parties in
one nation
there are numbers of successionists in
the north and doubtless
even still many union men of the south
when peace is declared those men
will go back the abolition of slavery
and of the three-fifths vote
will take the wind out of the sales of
the southern aristocracy
after the guerrillas here have been
exterminated the contending parties in
the civil war in america on both sides
are of english blood
germans and irish are mere accessories
the principles in the duel are
anglo-saxon and when once it is known
who is the stronger the mass on the
other side
will acquiesce the war must go on
until the weaker party succumbs
if ever a nation deserve to live it is
the united states
of america
soon i saw a sight i shall never forget
the whole union army in the town about
25
000 men under general thomas left their
tents and huts and marched out
past fort wood in long winding columns
creeping into the valley and into line
of battle
round the town from fort wood it all
looked like a great review
but it was in deadly earnest at about
two o'clock the line of skirmishes began
to advance
and they crossed the open space in front
of me in two lines
they'd not gone far before the pop of
rifles showed that they had come across
the rebel pickets
the whole army then advanced in two
lines and plunged into the wood
at the front of missionary ridge the
musketry continued incessantly until
dark
the great guns on fort wood 32-pounder
parrots
opened fire 20 yards from where i stood
throwing shells on the ridge opposite
wounded men limped back up towards us
and general thomas stood watching close
by me
ambulances hurried forward for the badly
hurt the men
cheered as they charged very soon a
bunch of about
200 rebel prisoners were brought in
rough and ragged men with no vestige of
a uniform
but with good shoes and looking well fed
as they marched close by where
where general grant and general thomas
stood on fort wood
there was a great galloping of aids to
camp a hurrying of wagons and ambulances
and the scream of shells and the whistle
of bullets
the result of this afternoon's work is
that the rebel picket line
including a null called orchard knob
has been captured general thomas and his
army are lying out on the ground tonight
in the positions they have taken in the
valley
without tents and in the rain perhaps
they will storm the ridge
tomorrow i have been busy tonight
rolling bandages for a kind sister of
mercy here
131 men are in chattanooga for wounds
received today
i suppose there are more wounded who
have not yet been fetched in
this is a war with a vengeance
first thing after breakfast this morning
i went to fort wood
general thomas's men were still right
where we left them extending in a great
semi-circle
all the distance from the river above
chattanooga to the river
below towards lookout mountain
shells were being fired from fort wood
intermittently
the rebels in force were plainly visible
general howard's at one point on the top
of the missionary ridge
tents and men quite discernible
at ten o'clock we saw a number of
pontoons floating slowly down the river
at first this puzzled the spectators at
fort wood but it was soon learnt that
these pontoons had formed a bridge
by which general sherman's army had
crossed the tennessee river upstream
he now had no further use for them and
we knew he was safely across
i talked to a gunner of the michigan
battery manning fort wood
he was a regular sometime before the war
the guns are 32 pounder parrots
his shells have not been exploding too
often
i began to think nothing was doing until
about midday
when i was dividing my lunch with one of
the gunners on the fort
heavy reports of cannon and musketry
from lookout valley
made us all hurry to that side of fort
wood i joined two officers looking
through telescopes towards lookout
mountain
and we soon saw hooker attacking his men
plainly visible to us
sweeping round the steep face of lookout
close by me was general grant in a black
sertu
with black braid and on quite loose
black trousers
and a black wide awake hat and thin
wellington boots
he looked clean and gentlemanly but not
military
having a stoop and full reddish beard
the mustache
much lighter than the ends which were
trained into a peak
we saw hooker's men fall back once then
they advanced again
after some little suspense we saw the
rebels run round the face of lookout
near the top and hooker's line advanced
after them
rifles popping all along at the face of
the mountain and guns
shelling the retreating rebels from
moccasin point and fort negley
an officer beside me with a telescope
cried out
there they are and the rebels are
running his glass was pointed to the
steep face of lookout
more than halfway up and there sure
enough
just three miles from us along the
sparsely wooded face of the mountain
we saw a running fight with the rebels
retreating before hooker's men
furious cheering started on the federal
right down in the plain near the river
where they could see the action better
than we could from fort wood
spectators in the town of chattanooga
took up the cry and i never in my life
saw anything like the excitement on fort
wood
of all i saw and heard today the most
impressive circumstance was the cheering
of the union troops
marshaled in line of battle in the
position to which they advanced
yesterday
where they had passed a tentless night
and had been standing idle all morning
when hooker's men planted that large u.s
flag near the top of the mountain
the whole of the troops and the people
in and around chattanooga
who must number some sixty thousand at
least
seemed to hurrah together the only man
who seemed unmoved
was general grant himself the prime
author of all this
hurley burley there he stood in his
plain citizen's clothes
looking through his double field glasses
apparently
totally unmoved i stood within a few
feet of him
and i could hardly believe that here was
this famous commander
the model as it seemed to me of a modest
and homely but efficient
yankee general i stood next to general
grant for
some time if the battle had been a
pageant got up for my benefit i could
not have had it better
hooker telegraphed a general grant
saying that he had 500 prisoners
and all seemed to be going well when
rain came on and nothing more was
visible
so ended tuesday november 24th the
second day of the battle
when i came in from my walk i heard that
sherman had taken the northern point of
missionary ridge
and that hooker in the south had
affected his junction with thomas's
right
tomorrow morning either the rebels will
run or there will be a general attack
on their whole line it has been a
wonderful chance to see war on so
gigantic a scale under such unpleasant
circumstances
we feed capitally on the sanitary
commission stores
and sleep under a roof every night it
must be seldom that battles can be seen
like
this
[Music]
today a poor fellow walked up to fort
wood and lay down
and died in front of us deaths and
wounds
are horrible i never see a wounded man
without thinking how
wicked politicians are to begin a war
such as this
the flashes from the picket rifles on
lookout tonight is very beautiful to see
at a distance but close up one would see
lots of men chiefly of english descent
dodging about among trunks of trees and
rocks
one side in blue cloth and the other in
butternut cloth
but not in uniform shooting one another
whenever a chance offers like
indians when a man is wounded he must
limp or
crawl like a rabbit among the rocks
until picked up
and put on a painful stretcher and
carried with many jolts down the
mountain
to a still more painful ambulance than
perhaps to die of gangrene
in one of the crowded hospitals of
chattanooga
one supps full of horrors it is my
opinion that tomorrow
we'll see a very important episode of
the war and that many more men
on both sides will bite the dust
[Music]
you